ils ont fait beaucoup de bruit dans les
tribunes hollandais belges ou encore
Allemands les étrangers ont fait le
déplacement jusqu'au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
soutenir leur protéger pendant ces
mondiaux sur piste vraiment
pour supporter la Belgique
et
un favorite il a déjà gagné une heure
on a des médailles on espère qu'on a
avoir de plus je suis autrichien ma
femme est tellement
j'encourage la cour aux allemande Léa
Frédéric
d'or et vous pouvez entendre que j'ai
perdu ma voix
un peu plus loin on retrouve également
un supporter canadien qui a fait le
déplacement avec son grand chapeau il
est venu une journée sur place pour
supporter sa nièce c'était aussi pour
lui l'occasion de découvrir un vélo de
route de niveau international
je suis très impressionné par la vitesse
quand il y a une course
de ma vie et aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une réalité
dans l'air centrale des journalistes
venus des quatre coins de la planète
britannique américains ont encore
reconnaît son présent dans ce vélo
tourne national pour relayer les
informations ici une cinquantaine de
nationalité est présente
je suis ici pour filmer et enregistrer
les interviews des cyclistes japonais
présent sur les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
n'est pas hyper populaire au Japon
mais on est ici pour promouvoir ce sport
et intéresser le public japonais
j'étais déjà là en 2015
je choisis des photos avec de l'action
je choisis des photos où on voit bien
les visages des coureurs j'ai choisi des
actions pour illustrer la course et
l'action sur la piste
supporter et journaliste ont pris leur
marque dans la structure 50-hinoise à
l'occasion de ces championnats du monde
tout le monde se retrouvera dans moins
de 2 ans l'occasion des Jeux olympiques
de Paris en 2024